actress Scarlett Johansson says she
supports diversity in Hollywood that's
after some people accused her of making
controversial casting comments in a
recent interview for as if Magazine
Johansson said actors should be allowed
to play any person or any tree or any
animal it's not the first time she has
faced controversy in 2017 she came under
fire for playing an Asian character in
the movie ghosts in the show
well last year she canceled plans to
play a transgender man in the movie
rub-and-tug after transgender actors and
advocates questioned the casting in a
statement over the weekend Johansson
says quote in an ideal world art in all
forms should be immune to political
correctness but she acknowledged that in
reality the industry favors Caucasian
sister actors this is from a
screenwriter she says ScarJo you should
be able to play a tree because there
aren't countless sentient trees desiring
to act yet struggling to get cast and
roles that's from Stefanie Mick as she's
a screenwriter in Hollywood get up that
tweet there